لدينا أخبار عاجلة من أوكرانيا حيث
تقصف روسيا
مدينة أوديسا الساحلية الجنوبية لليلة الثالثة على
التوالي، يمكنك مشاهدة هذا الفيديو الاستثنائي
من فريق CNN، ويظهر أن
الدفاع الجوي الأوكراني يعمل على صد
هذه الهجمات الروسية،
وينضم أليكس ماركهارت من CNN  أنا أعيش من أوديسا أليكس،
ما الذي كنت تراه
على الأرض لأن هذه هي الليلة الثالثة
على التوالي التي نعرف فيها أن هذا قد حدث
وهل هناك إحساس بنوع
الأسلحة التي تستخدمها روسيا
هنا؟  كان هذا بالفعل على حافة الهاوية
بعد ليلتين من
الهجمات الشرسة المكثفة للغاية من قبل روسيا،
وتتساءل هذه المدينة عما إذا كان سيحدث
لليلة الثالثة على التوالي، وجاء الرد
قبل الساعة الثانية صباحًا بقليل بهجوم
استمر حوالي ساعة و45
دقيقة، وهو ما يمكن القول إنه الأكثر  مكثفة ولكن فيما
يتعلق بالأسلحة التي رأيناها
معروضة الليلة، فقد بدأت بنفس
الطريقة التي بدأت بها في الليلتين الماضيتين مع
صفارات إنذار الغارات الجوية التي تحذر مواطني
هذه المدينة ثم كان هناك هجوم قادم ثم
بدأنا في رؤية طلقات التتبع الحمراء
من  الدفاعات الجوية تطلق النار
في السماء وتضيء سماء الليل
بحثًا عن طائرات بدون طيار لإسقاطها كانت هناك
أضواء كاشفة كانت تبحث عن
طائرات بدون طيار رأينا صواريخ اعتراضية
تقلع وتضرب أه
الأشياء لأنه كانت هناك
انفجارات ضخمة في السماء ألقت  هذا
التوهج الضخم في جميع أنحاء هذه المدينة والذي
أظلم في النهاية،
وتم إطفاء جميع الأضواء لأسباب
أمنية، ولكن يبدو أن السبب في أن
هذا كان أكثر
كثافة الليلة هو بسبب
تنوع صواريخ كروز على الأقل
ثلاثة أنواع مختلفة  من صواريخ كروز التي
استخدمتها روسيا، بما في ذلك
صاروخ كينزال المخيف للغاية والذي يحتوي على
رأس حربي يزن طنًا واحدًا، نعلم أن روسيا
أرسلت ما لا يقل عن ثمانية
قاذفات استراتيجية بعيدة المدى الأسرع من الصوت لإطلاق
صواريخ كروز هذه،
ونعلم بشكل ملحوظ أنه في كل هذه الصواريخ
تم استخدام طائرات بدون طيار للهجوم ولكن كانت هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي نسمع فيها هذه
الطائرات بدون طيار قريبة جدًا لدرجة أنها تبدو وكأنها بعوض ضخم
يطير بالقرب من
المباني. ما هي الأهداف
وما هو الضرر لدرجة أننا لا نعرف أن
الشمس تشرق للتو  لكنني أعتقد أنه من
العدل أن نقول إن هذه الليالي الثلاث الأخيرة
مثلت أخطر
الهجمات على أوديسا منذ أن بدأت هذه الحرب
العام الماضي،
لقد مر شهر منذ هذا
التمرد الفاشل، وهذا هو أول
دليل نراه على الميليشيا  على
الأرض، أول عرض فعلي لما
نعتقد أنهم مقاتلو فاغنر، أريد أن
أعرض لكم بعضًا من تلك الصور لمحاولة
شرح ما نراه، هذه
صور الأقمار الصناعية التي تظهر أعتقد أنه
يمكنك رؤية نوع من الطريق يلتف حولنا
هناك منحدر خارج الطريق السريع
متجهًا إلى هذه القاعدة العسكرية في
بيلاروسيا، حيث يمكنك رؤية صف من السيارات
على طول هذا الطريق المستقيم عبر
منتصف الصورة متجهًا إلى
القاعدة هناك ونعتقد أن هذه
سيارات مرتبطة بـ
شركة فاغنر العسكرية الخاصة لأن فريقنا
تمكن من مطابقتها مع مقطع
فيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تم نشره سابقًا يُظهر
صفًا من السيارات وقافلة أه، لقد
توقفت على طريق سريع في روسيا ترفع
أعلام فاغنر، الآن ما يلفت النظر في
هذا العدد الهائل من  هذه
المركبات التي نعتقد أن هناك حوالي 150
مركبة مختلفة في هذه القافلة
بشكل منفصل عن أننا تمكنا من
تحديد الموقع الجغرافي لمقطعي فيديو آخرين على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
أه تظهر قوافل جديدة تحتوي كل منها على
حوالي 100 مركبة أو نحو ذلك على الطرق السريعة
في روسيا متجهة إلى "نحن نؤمن"  تجاه
بيلاروسيا، يشير هذا إلى أن
مقاتلي فاغنر يقومون الآن بزيادة
أعدادهم في هذا المعسكر المهجور سابقًا
في بيلاروسيا. وقد زار فريقنا
هذا المعسكر منذ بضعة أسابيع فقط
ووجد أنه لم يكن هناك أي
مقاتلين من فاغنر هناك في تلك المرحلة، لذا
يبدو أن هذا  كان تطورًا جديدًا نسبيًا، فقد
أبلغنا
حرس الحدود الأوكرانيين يوم
السبت أن فاغنر كانت موجودة
بالفعل في بيلاروسيا. وقالت بيلاروسيا نفسها إن
فاغنر تقوم بتدريب قواتها،
لكن هذا مهم لأنه على الرغم من
أنك تعلم أن الرئيس بوتين يقول إن فاغنر
لا تفعل ذلك.  لا توجد تلميحات حول احتمال أن
تعرف أنهم قريبون الآن من
الحدود الأوكرانية، وله دور مستقبلي في هذا
الصراع، كما أنه قوة مزعزعة للاستقرار في
المنطقة، لذا بالتأكيد تريد مواصلة
المشاهدة